so he was literally sitting right here
there's a three and a half hour dinner
and and it was endless it was a long
dinner but I really got the sense of who
it was endless
um but I I got the sense of who DeSantis
really is right outside of uh you know
how the the team presents him on Twitter
and all this other stuff and so this is
the thing this person is whip smart this
is a very very very smart man this is a
very smart individual policy wise okay I
think the issue that he is going to have
is mb's interactions with regular people
the the sort of small talk the things
that you have to do is somebody that's
an entrepreneur somebody that is a
politician or somebody that is a public
figure these are not things that come
natural to him and it becomes a very
obvious uh when you spend more than five
minutes with him the opportunity there
and the threat there is to have a very
negative viral moment where he's kind of
just being a little awkward the left
takes that blows it up